[Musique]
si je vous dis que le plat qui est
derrière moi dans cette assiette est un
plat chaud
à quoi pensez-vous ade à la coque
peut-être eh bien non c'est une omelette
mais pas n'importe quel omelette c'est
la première omelette au monde à avoir
été réalisée sans casser les oeufs et
qui plus est qui plus est en faisant
cuire séparément les blancs et les
jaunes dans une poêle avant de les
remixer impossible vous ne me croyez pas
et pourtant
revenons en arrière il y a quatre ans
nous sommes à montréal dans une école de
business management ou un grand concours
est organisé pour une centaine de cadres
managers en recherche de créativité
le challenge qui leur est proposé et de
faire cuire une omelette en 30 minutes
par équipe de sept à huit
provenant de différents pays ne parlant
pas tous forcément la même langue et de
devoir présenter cette omelette au bout
de 30 minutes devant un jury
international composé de chefs étoilés
de designers et qui vont les évaluer de
la manière suivante un peu comme au
patinage avec une autre technique et une
note artistique
l'une pour le goût et l'autre pour la
créativité dans l'équipe où je me trouve
la première question surgit soudain qui
se faire cuire un oeuf qui a déjà fait
cuire une omelette 2 sur 8
mal parti pour gagner le concours
tout au moins sur le plan du goût reste
la créativité une omelette original mais
oui quoi de plus original que de faire
une omelette sans casser les oeufs yes
but c'est impossible quand vous avez une
idée originale créative
n'avez vous jamais entendu cette réponse
à ça vous oui mais c'est pas possible
oui mais on a déjà essayé ou là tu ne
peux pas le yes but
la première limite pour sortir de la
créativité et c'est ce qui se passe dans
l'équipe tout de suite demain saisissent
les oeufs en disant qu'à son lait nous
avons perdu suffisamment temps regarder
les autres équipes
attendons encore une minute
réfléchissons l'idée est trop bonne si
nous sommes capables de faire une
omelette sans casser les oeufs nous
sommes sûrs de gagner le concours
quel que soit son goût alors comment
faire des couteaux des fourchettes
quelques instruments nous décidions de
commencé à percer un peu les coquilles 1
mm 2 mm 3 et de les secouer
frénétiquement pour essayer de faire
sortir les blancs ce qui n'est pas
facile
4 mm 5 mm en même temps deux minutes
trois minutes 4 minutes cinq minutes
nous finissions par être découragés
leblanc ne sortait pas il fallait casser
les oeufs finalement et rattraper le
retard
et puis sur l'un d eux le blanc apparaît
au miracle quelle joie de voir du blanc
à paraître dans neuf
nous tirons nous tirons comme nous
pouvons et puis la force de ce coût est
de secouer les blancs finissent par
tomber dans l'assiette les trois blancs
des 3
nous avions inventé sans le savoir par
le plus grand des hasards une nouvelle
méthode pour séparer les blancs des
jaunes sans utiliser de tasse vide vers
les blancs étaient là devant nous
restent et les jeunes comment faire
toujours sur la même table nous
observions de petits pics à fromage
genre de cure-dents en bois décoratifs
et nous eurent l'idée d'en prendre
quelques-uns pour percer les jeunes à
travers ce petit trou en perçant les
jeunes ils se mirent à couler
immédiatement miracle le temps perdu
avec les blancs étaient rattrapés avec
les jeunes et les jeunes se mettaient à
coup coulé dans une autre assiette et
nous avions devant nous tout ce qu'il
fallait pour faire une omelette à ce
moment-là de membres de notre équipe
prirent les blancs et les jaunes et
courir à la cuisine ou une poêle les
attendait pour faire cuire ces blancs et
ses jeunes de manière séparée avant de
les mixer dixit le secret de l'omelette
de la mère poulard d'eau
mont-saint-michel qui fait qu'en faisant
comme cela l'omelette à un meilleur goût
les autres membres de l'équipe autour de
la table se pose est bien la question
quand l'omelette va revenir comment
va-t-on faire puisque nous avons trois
coquilles percée d'un petit trou
effectivement quand l'omelette revient
dans une assiette large et pèse baveuse
on se rend compte qu à nouveau c'est
impossible
yes but mais l'un d'entre nous des
coupes la nappe en papier confectionne
de petits cônes genre d'entonnoir et
nous essayons de remplir les coquilles
avec des morceaux d'omelette que nous
avions pin est détruite
nick est fier pour tasser l'omelette et
ça fonctionne nous remplissons
progressivement les 10% 20% mais le
chronomètre tourne il ne reste plus que
quatre à cinq minutes
jamais nous n'aurons le temps de remplir
les yeux jusqu'au
nous avions préparé une petite crème
persillé juste pour décorer l'assiette
quelle bonne idée la crème elle va nous
sauver nous prenons la crème et nous la
version dans les eaux nous gagnons
beaucoup de temps ils se remplissent
plus vite une couche de crème une couche
d'eau met une couche de craine une
couche d'omelette deux minutes une
minute trente secondes nous bouchons les
jeux avec de petits bouts de fromage
nous retournant les oeufs dans
l'assiette
arrivée devant le jury
moments mémorables des des rires dans la
salle
je vois le regard qu'ils se disent les
petits plaisantins ils ont fait 3 oeufs
à la coque créatif et nous présentons
l'omelette de manière magistrale
l'omelette à la coque
la première omelette au monde réalisé
sans casser les oeufs les membres du
jury
incrédule nous disent mais commencement
comment se mange cette omelette comme un
oeuf à la coque mais c'est une omelette
il casse le haut de l'oeuf ou velopper
recul et commence à goûter
l'un d'entre eux disant même ils sont au
chaud oui ils viennent d'être pondu donc
il arrive direct il goûte les uns après
les autres mais elle est bonne mais
c'est de l'omelette
elle est très bonne mais attendez il y à
de la crème nom de la crème est à
nouveau de l'omelette dix équipes 30
minutes
une idée géniale un yes butt et nous
gagnons le concours vous l'avez deviné
je ne suis pas cuisinier je suis
professeur d'université
j'enseigne la génétique la biologie
moléculaire à l'université et je me dis
peut-on innové en pédagogie sans casser
les oeufs plutôt que d'enseigner de
manière magistrale toujours de la même
manière en transmettant sa connaissance
face à des élèves ou des étudiants qui
vous écoute qui rédige qui notent qu'ils
apprennent qu'ils répliquent pourrait-on
orchestré son cours de manière
différente et faire preuve de créativité
yes dot n'est pas évident
beaucoup d'enseignants ont essayé des
classes inversée des serious games des
cartes mentales des apprentissages par
projet toute une batterie d'innovation
pour ma part je me décide d'aller plus
loin de pousser les limites de
l'impossible après tout puisque j'ai
fait une omelette sans casser des oeufs
qui peut m'arrêter
j'en parle à mes collègues d'université
et je leur dit écoutez j'ai une idée qui
va vous paraître peut-être stupide mais
je la trouve intéressante et si je
demandais à mes étudiants de tout faire
par eux-mêmes
autrement dit on un autre mot je ne fais
plus rien ils font tout ils me répondent
yes c'est original me botte
impossible alors je décide de me lancer
et il ya quatre ans devant mes étudiants
aligner un peu comme vous devant moi les
meilleurs devant les moyens au milieu et
[Applaudissements]
et les moins bons en génétique au fond
parce que je suppose que dans d'autres
cours vous placez différemment je leur
dis moi je vous propose pas la classe à
verser je vous propose le do it yourself
autrement dit vous faites les cours vous
même vous allez chercher l'information
vous rédigez les cours vous faites les
cours vous interrogez vous formuler des
questions vous fabriquer les examens
nous distribuer le copie vous remplissez
des copies vous ramasser les copies vous
corriger les copies et moi je suis là
pour vous aider
depuis quatre ans mes étudiants
utilisent les exercices vraiment
intéressant des cut-scènes averses et
des qcm intelligente des tricheries
obligatoire et ils font tourner les
tableaux ils font tourner les tableaux
plutôt que je perde du temps alors
expliquer des choses avec un schéma
je leur demande de co-construire par eux
mêmes ce qu'ils trouvent sur des
tableaux toutes les trois minutes je
l'ait fait changer de position il
complète le travail des autres équipes
et à la fin nous dirigeons vers le
tableau le plus complet et je leur donne
l'explication
alors pour réussir l'impossible tels que
vous venez de comprendre il y a deux
secrets le premier secret c'est de
sortir de sa zone de confiance
le premier secret c'est de prendre des
risques d'accepter de ne plus être
l'expert celui qui s'est osé dire à ses
élèves
je ne sais pas apprends moi le deuxième
secret c'est que les étudiants entre se
fasse non seulement confiance mais
s'entraident qu'ils apprennent à
travailler différemment et en même temps
que ses étudiants fassent confiance aux
professeurs qui se mettent non plus
alors enseigner la matière uniquement
mais à les accompagner de manière plus
pédagogue pédagogue
savez vous que le pédagogue n'est pas un
prof dans l'antiquité le pédagogue était
un esclave sans connaissance qui
conduisait l'enfant de la maison à
l'école l'enfant apprenait du maître et
le pédagogue ramener l'enfant de l'école
à la maison sans doute le protégeant sur
le chemin peut-être les dents à faire
ses devoirs
la pédagogie c'est de l'accompagnement
alors innové en pédagogie oui mais
pourquoi ne pas aussi innové en
évaluation comment évaluer les étudiants
la note sur 20
peut-on s'affranchir de cette
sacro-sainte note sur 20
donc tu n'as pas le droit je n'ai pas le
droit alors je le fais
je désobéis l'innovation finalement
c'est une désobéissance qui réussit je
tente et je transforme
mais note sur 20 ans points en bon point
pour construire des scores je réhabilite
finalement les bons points et j'en ai
plein les poches pour tout travail qui
est fait par équipe ou individuellement
je donne des points ce qui me permet de
noter non seulement leurs capacités à
apprendre mais en même temps leur
développement de compétences sont ils
capables de céder entre eux vous savez
qu'il ya une chose qui n'est jamais
évalué à l'école avec une note sur 20
c'est salman khan qui le dit le fondeur
de la khan academy c'est la capacité
qu'a un élève à aider ses camarades de
classe or on sait qu'un élève qui aide
ses camarades de classe demain c'est un
collègue de travail qui va aider ses
collaborateurs donc il faut travailler
en ce sens changer la note sur 20 pour
un prof c'est assez facile puisque à la
fin finalement du semestre
rien n'empêche de transformer un bon
point en note sur 20 pour le secrétariat
bien sûr mais pour les étudiants c'est
différent je les valorisant leur offrant
un capital points et ils s'enrichissent
à chaque fois qu'ils viennent dans mes
cours je ne retire jamais toi personne
ne cherche à avoir la moyenne
tout le monde cherche à en s'enrichir en
point alors pourrait-on le faire
ensemble
je décidé de le faire avec des preuves
de prépa des profs de classes
préparatoires qui adore la note sur 20
et je leur proposais d' inventer
ensemble de co dessiner ensemble une
nouvelle méthode jamais expérimenté pour
noter les élèves sans notes sur 20 cents
lettres a b c d sans code couleur sans
exploser sans copie sans mémoire bref en
leur interdisant tout ce qui était
possible de faire
yes but
et pour les aider parce que je ne suis
pas sadique je leur proposais tout
simplement d'utiliser un outil
formidable le baby foot
comment évaluer le niveau de
connaissance de vos élèves en
mathématiques par le baby foot c'est
impossible on n'y arrivera pas mais
mettez-vous par équipes
je vous propose une méthode de cow
design de travail collaboratif avec des
méthodes de divergences de convergence
et on verra bien quelles sont vos idées
il y avait toujours un groupe de profs
dix ans on n'y arrivera pas je leur
répondais dépêchez vous les autres ont
commencé le travail vous perdez du temps
30 minutes quelle ne fut pas quelle ne
fut pas notre surprise de voir au bout
de deux heures et demie des profs de
prépa nous proposer quelque chose
d'incroyable un tournoi de baby foot de
trois heures avec des poules de
qualification des huitièmes de finale
des quarts de finale des demi finale des
finales qui donne un classement complet
des étudiants du meilleur en
mathématiques jusqu'au moins bon et pour
empêcher qu'un champion de france de
baby foot ne gagne l'examen un système
de bonus et de malus
les étudiants répondant sur des
tablettes à des questions de maths
obtenant des bonus quand ils connaissent
la réponse exemple j'ai le droit de
tirer dix fois le penalty jusqu'à ce que
je réussisse ou des malus
lorsque leur niveau en maths est faible
exemple je dois jouer au baby-foot les
yeux bandés avec une main en levant un
pied à trois mètres du but
à la fin un classement de trois heures
d'épreuve de tournois ludique pour les
étudiants et qui vous donne le
classement des élèves selon leur niveau
mathématique incroyable et cadeaux pour
le prof plus de copies à corriger le
week-end des dizaines d'heures à se
consacrer à ses plaisirs ses loisirs sa
famille la créativité avoir de nouvelles
idées
l'innovation quand l'idée rencontre la
main de l'utilisateur deux choses
différentes pour passer de la créativité
à l'innovation
il faut expérimenter ne pas avoir peur
du yes but et surtout se rappeler d'une
chose ne jamais abandonner les
fondamentaux un peu comme la canopée
d'une forêt ce lieu de biodiversité
si intéressant il n'existerait pas s'il
n'y avait pas les troncs des arbres aux
aspects si simple et si rigide
l'innovation pédagogique ne fonctionne
pas si vous ne respectez pas les
disciplines dans l'entreprise c'est la
même chose
innover nécessite de respecter
l'académique l'omelette même la plus
originale du monde reste une omelette au
goût d'omelette le cours de génétique
même renversé reste un cours de
génétique
alors pour finir s'il fallait ne retenir
qu'une seule chose dites vous qu avoir
des idées les transmettre aux et prendre
des risques
sortir des limites passé à
l'expérimentation est quelque chose
d'extrêmement motivant et puis surtout
refuser les idées reçues surtout quand
il s'agit de dictons et dites vous que
on est capable de tout lorsqu'on sait
faire cuire une omelette sans casser les
oeufs
[Applaudissements]